[Music]
it's the ocean verse the Dutch that's
the battle that's going on right now
it's been going on for hundreds of years
and you know who's winning the Dutch
[Music]
fill that water super ingenious the way
they designed it can't you tell the
engineering look at this map of Holland
in 1300 compare this to a map of Holland
today the country has gained land yes
thousands and thousands of square
kilometers of land has been won back
from the ocean the story of this battle
between the ocean and the Dutch explains
why Holland is good at cheese why
Amsterdam has canals why Dutch people
ride bikes and for those who are
confused the Dutch Netherlands and
Holland are all the same thing and they
all have different reasons and I'm not
going to go into them you can like look
at Wikipedia this is just when I use
those words it all has to do with the
same thing which is this country okay
so the Netherlands or Holland or
whatever you want to call it is a
country that is sink it's actually the
majority of it is under sea level or
right at sea level I mean if you look at
the map of Holland you see that a lot of
it is just these little strips of land
that are right up in the North Sea and
the ocean and the wind just kind of eat
away at this land
year after year instead of fleeing these
coastal communities that were slowly
sinking into the water about 500 years
ago the Dutch started to fight back now
let's just be clear about one thing
which is fighting the ocean the
incessant timeless powerhouse the ocean
is a very difficult thing where are we
going
what Texel we made it this battle
between the Netherlands and the ocean
it's now much more real for me this wind
and these waves are so breezy and
consistent they're too easy this land
alive and yet the Netherlands have
decided to fight back and they're doing
a pretty darn good job Holland is up for
this task they've developed a whole
system a whole science behind
hydrological engineering that has
allowed them to combat the effects and
the erosion of the ocean my favorite is
the curry ketchup Johnny loves the
handles and they actually go really well
together my gosh
[Music]
okay so how do they actually do this
this is where it gets really interesting
there are a few techniques that the
Dutch use for their wizardry over the
water the first one has to do with them
building a wall around a body of water
that they want to turn into land build a
wall around it and then they back in the
day would build a windmill next to those
walls and they would use the windmill to
spin and as the windmill would spin that
would spin a pump that would pump the
water out of that land
they'll plant on it and they will do
whatever they need to do to actually
make it firm dry habitable land and then
they'll build entire cities on and then
in 1932 Holland had a huge win there's
this giant part of the country that was
a part of the sea and they finally built
this huge wall building this giant wall
created a barrier between the saltwater
sea and made this huge body of water
into a freshwater lake after they built
this wall they then started to section
off little pieces of this newly created
lake and just start to turn those into
land as well so this is all of the land
that they have created since 1932 when
they built a wall to make this Lake I
mean it's totally crazy
the Netherlands actually a few years ago
got a new province like a new state in
their country not because of any
administrative reform but because they
literally reclaimed a giant piece of
land that used to be under the sea
so much of the Dutch coast line looks
like this just super fortified with
asphalt and a million other building
materials that they have come to over
hundreds and hundreds of years of
experimentation it seems simple it's a
wall but in this walls lies a secret to
Mohammed not sinking and they don't
always work there have been times when
these walls break but for the most part
this has been a success story
[Music]
but it's not just creating land out of
water it's also just how they manage
water in every one of their cities
[Music]
Amsterdam used to just be I mean you can
hear it in the name a dam on the Amstel
River they then built it up and they
created this series of canals a very
intentional design as you can see and in
doing so they made this city a very
accessible boat city which was a very
lucrative thing to do back in like the
fifteen and 1600s Amsterdam became an
economic hub in Europe and developed
very quickly the population boom and
contributed to the Golden Age of Holland
and even today Amsterdam is a giant
economic and global hub which you can
attribute to how the Dutch have just
mastered water and learnt how to
intentionally design their cities in
their country around water management a
[Music]
lot of the things we think of as
quintessential Dutch come from this
culture of water management and now that
sounds like the wonky is sing in the
world but listen to me here see the
bikes the bikes are a product of this
lowland because when you have flat land
it's relatively close together because
as most of your land is waterlogged then
bikes become a really efficient viable
transportation means you also have some
of the most fertile grounds in the world
for growing grass which then becomes
fertile pastures for cows which produce
amazing dairy products which is why
Dutch cheese is such wonderful amazing
cheese and then of course there are
windmills windmills are a huge Dutch
thing windmills come from this history
of pumping water
lakes and the ocean to create new pieces
of land for a long time windmills were
the technology which is why Holland is
full of windmills finally you have these
tulips tulips are another huge Dutch
thing the reason for this is that tulips
grow in this special clay sand soil
mixture and a lot of that exact soil is
right here in Holland because of the
fact that a lot of this land was under
water before they reclaimed it and so
it's perfect for growing tulips so a lot
of Dutch culture could be attributed to
water management and conquering the
water I hope you now understand why
Amsterdam has canals and the marvel of
Dutch water management so much more to
learn
I want to thank Skillshare for
sponsoring this video Skillshare is an
online platform for courses and it's a
community where you can learn tons of
stuff from video production to animation
to creative and entrepreneurial skills
there are thousands of really
high-quality courses that you can have
unlimited access to 4i things like 10
bucks a month if you sign up for the
annual subscription so it's like pretty
darn cheap I learned all of my skills in
an online learning course environment
including Skillshare courses and I
really recommend them if you're
interested in fueling your curiosity and
learning something new or even fueling
your business and professional skills
because they're sponsoring this video
you can click the link in the
description and get two months free of
unlimited access to all these courses so
you don't pay anything for two months so
you can test it out and see if it's a
good fit for you you click that link in
the description then it will take you to
the place where you can sign up there's
a fantastic course on Skillshare about
camera transitions which I use a lot the
idea of being able to make really fun
and creative transitions just using your
camera instead of fancy effects or
software I found that to be a really
useful course and you made - if you're
interested in this kind of camera work
so go sign up for Skillshare if you want
to test it out for free for two months
and thank you Skillshare for sponsoring
this video and making it possible for me
to make these more in
death explainers which kind of take a
lot of time but I hope you learned a lot
and I'll see you in the next one
[Music]